oh don't worry about it the details are
in the fine print but just
sign and we'll move forward
[Music]
hey there folks this is
it's not really going to be about hp on
hbo max
but we are going to start there because
i feel like um starting there allows me
to expand out into a bigger conversation
that
i
really wish was being had
more than i see
because
all the stuff going on with hbo every
problem everything going on and i'll get
into some of the specifics because
there's definitely a specific thing i'm
gonna pick on to uh really exemplify the
point where i'm going with this like
all sorts of people are calling this out
as bs from consumers to
insiders the stock has taken a hit like
everyone seems to be going like this is
nonsense the thing is
it's nonsense that is kind of indicative
of a lot of what other companies either
have done
are doing more quietly
or have the ability to do and probably
will do in the future so quick refresher
warner brothers has merged with
discovery it's now warner brothers
discovery they have a new ceo a new ceo
who is very focused on
i'm sure his words would probably be
trimming the fat i've talked about some
of this already i did a video previously
i am going to focus in on hbo as i
mentioned before
now a lot of stuff that's going on with
hbo we've we already know they're ending
hbo max they're merging with discovery
plus it'll be a new thing by this time
next year who knows what it'll be called
or what'll be on it because
sort of where i want to leap off on this
is
people
have taken notice that
stuff is being removed from the platform
without warning without notice it's just
gone now in terms of what stuff well
it's the kind of stuff that's consistent
with what ceo david zaslov has said he
wants the platform to be which is to
de-emphasize
um animation de-emphasize things for
children de-emphasize anything that is
not you know big budget and pulling in a
lot and
never i don't think he said this part
out loud but de-emphasizing anything
that doesn't pull significant numbers
even if it is beloved so
i'm going to pick a specific show
to use as an example there are plenty of
other shows this is not a comprehensive
list of everything that has or will be
pulled off
but i'm going to start by talking about
the show infinity train
infinity train is an animated series
that i did reviews on over in the break
room of geeks and it's a show i love it
got four seasons they wanted to do more
a lot of people don't like the fourth
season that much i actually do like it
though i get why it bugs some people
especially as it being the last season
but the overall thing is they had four
seasons it was very niche it was
sci-fi-ish it had a very you know
devoted fan base but it wasn't a big
huge runaway hit they managed to get
four seasons which is good would have
liked to have seen more it wasn't
pulling in the numbers it got canceled
and that was before the merger to be
clear it happens
but now it's gone off the platform
it's not there anymore
you can't watch it on hbo max anymore
but because it was produced
for hbo max and the rights to it are
held
by hbo and warner brothers
that means
you can't see it streaming anywhere
legally
at all
it's gone
and
it goes a little worse
than even that because if you're
thinking well okay
well you can still get physical copies
right well
no first of all only two of the four
seasons ever got released to physical
media there were dvds made available the
first two seasons there were never dvds
made available of the second two seasons
and coincidentally i'm sure
almost immediately after the show was
pulled off hbo max
the dvds are no longer available for
purchase
you can't buy them other than second
hand now
now you can in theory still digitally
purchase the show on something like
amazon for the time being there's no
guarantee that that will remain true and
i would actually at this point not be
surprised at all if it's also gone from
there i can't remember if this is the
case with infinity train or not but
definitely with some of the shows that
have been pulled hbo max has also
removed all promotional material from
their youtube channels any trailers
officially that had been put up it's
like they're trying to scrub the fact
that it ever existed at all
so
what i want to use this as a chance to
talk about
is the concept of digital ownership
how flimsy that concept is
how unsupported
it is how quickly it can be taken away
and how this fits into a larger world
that corporations are trying
in fits and starts and have been for
some time to build and make us live in
where we own nothing and subscribe
for everything
so let's
be fair
fair and let's acknowledge the reasons
that a a company like hbo like warner
brothers might have for removing these
things other than some nonsense like it
doesn't fit our corporate portfolio
because if that was the case
theoretically you could just sell it
sell it to somebody else sell it to
crunchyroll they have all sorts of weird
niche animated stuff so it's a shutter
it's got horror elements somebody will
buy it it'll still be available
somewhere it'll be a pain to have to go
to a different service to still see it
but it would still be there
so that's the first thing they are not
even opting to unload these assets in
any meaningful way they're just revoking
the ability
for consumers for fans to ever have
access to them again
and the primary reason other than as i
mentioned this nonsense about our
corporate portfolio and all that kind of
crap is to reduce costs
because server costs are a thing and it
costs them money to host on the servers
and make available to stream at a decent
definition and everything it costs the
money to have these things sitting
around and if they're not being viewed
by that many people
from one perspective you can say well
that
we're not getting our money's worth on
that just scrap it
now
there are other perspectives that could
say it's worth keeping around even the
stuff that isn't that heavily viewed
because having a wide variety of stuff
is never a bad thing and unless
something is like hated if something has
a passionate fan base keep it around
because maybe that fan base was
passionate about that and they're here
and now they'll find other things but
you start taking that away from them
well you're gonna have some people who
start to go well clearly the kinds of
things that i like won't be here anymore
i should leave
so there is kind of a holistic approach
to offering a wide variety of things
and the idea that yes you have your big
huge mainstream things you have your
game of thrones series you have your dc
related stuff and all that but you also
have the smaller niche things that
really get people hooked in to stay
because
you know the big mainstream stuff people
show up for but people stay because they
find stuff that feels like it's much
more just for them
and that's the stuff that's being taken
away right now
but as i said to be fair there is the
raw numbers perspective it's costing us
money to host this let's not spend that
money anymore
and that's about the only bone i'm going
to throw
to corporations in regards to all of
this because from any consumer
perspective this
is
not good at all
because this
removes our ability to enjoy something
a piece of art
that
we loved
and now it's gone
now i'm not going to dwell on this too
quickly but
you know
my feelings about piracy have evolved
over the years i for the record i don't
pirate stuff i don't and i don't
encourage people to pirate but the
reason i don't pirate things has changed
when i was younger when i was in my 20s
i had a more philosophical stance of you
know you should pay for the things to
help ensure that the artists get money
and like with some mediums like if
you're pirating say music from an indie
label or something that an artist
released themselves yeah you are
actually taking money out of people's
pockets but like from big corporation i
don't really think that anymore aside
from the fact that there's been a number
of studies that kind of back up the idea
that uh a pirated copy is not actually a
lost sale and generally most pirates are
people who were never going to pay for
it and they're only getting it because
they can get it for free so the idea
that piracy is a lost sale doesn't
really hold up anyway but like i said
when i was in my
20s early 30s i had a more philosophical
notion as to why i didn't pirate these
days it's just purely just paranoia and
logistical i'm a little bit of a jinx
with technology so like i don't trust
basically going off brand and like i
swear every time i mess with
mods for programs or like use this third
party program to get your thing to do
this or access this thing this way like
something goes wrong and i don't mean
like i accidentally downloaded a virus
though i don't like that possibility
either i just mean like it breaks
something in a way that makes no sense
to me and everyone was like well that
shouldn't happen i'm like i understand
it shouldn't but it did but my point is
at this point i don't pirate because
i'm just paranoid about my about my
computer breaking
so
that's why i don't do it now but i don't
have that philosophical argument anymore
because you know when i did pirate
way back when i was in college than
after days oh yeah those were the days
but you know i kind of stopped pirating
once things like itunes came out and you
could just buy the albums and buy the
music directly
i'm not gonna say stop completely but i
did pirate a little bit at that point
the times i did
was when i couldn't get access to
something because i use well i still i
like video game soundtracks a lot and
back then before music streaming became
a thing
it was actually quite difficult to
to get a lot of video game soundtracks
through legitimate means a lot of
soundtracks never got actually pressed
onto cds or if they did it was like only
in japan and you'd have to pay import
costs to get them over here
and if i felt like i could not attain
something either at all or at what was
what anyone would consider a reasonable
price my thought is
if you're not giving me the ability to
give you a reasonable amount of money
for it yes i will pirate it
and i feel like that is a situation that
things like what hbo is doing now is
creating i generally
actually i don't think i've ever said
that i've
i've never rung the bell of you are
encouraging piracy here you actually are
you're making it so there is no way for
customers to get the thing they want
other than to as far as you are
concerned steal it
funny thing about stealing
is that uh
even outside of streaming services
even if you're thinking okay but you
know the things i really care about i
buy
i buy digital copies of
those can be taken away from you
those can be stolen back
by
whatever service you got it through
and the thing is
people who are concerned about
digital ownership who are concerned
about
customer rights and concerned about the
consumers
they've been saying this for a very long
time but it's largely been brushed off
because for the most part it's been a
theoretical problem
but the thing about theoretical problems
that you don't put in safeguards to
prevent is they eventually become real
problems and we are now starting to see
that and i'll give you a couple of
specific examples of how it is starting
to crop up so we're going to start with
sony and the playstation store so back
in 2021 sony discontinued the ability to
purchase tv or movies through the
playstation store service they decide to
restrict we're just doing games through
this service now and prior to that you
could buy movies or tv episodes i don't
think that many people did that's
probably why they discontinued it now at
the time that they did that people who
had already purchased stuff and it was
in their movie library or whatever
they still got to have it it was fine no
problem
yeah there started to be a problem
though so in july of this year sony
removed all of the uh films and
television that was owned by studio
canal
from its service and that included
removing it from the digital libraries
of people who had actually bought it
through the playstation store
they took it
back
now if you're wondering why haven't you
heard about this well it's pretty
underreported largely because it only
affected two territories germany and
austria now the reason in this case had
to do with changes in the licensing
agreement between sony and studio canal
they reached some kind of impasse in
these territories for whatever reason
and an agreement couldn't be reached so
they had to pull the stuff back
now
some of you who might be more inclined
to defend the corporations if you are
i'm not sure why you're on my channel
but like just to indulge the idea you
might be thinking okay but that's a
copyright dispute they didn't
maliciously take stuff back
well yeah that's true except you know
what happens to your dvds or your
blu-rays of movies if there's a
copyright dispute and
something has to be discontinued and
it's not allowed to be sold at any point
further into the future
on on that medium
nothing
you still have your dvds you still have
your blu-rays
this kind of stuff should not impact
things that you
bought
most people would assume that it doesn't
but it does when you're talking
streaming and when you're talking
digital now it is possible through
legislation to put protections in place
to demand basically as much as is
reasonably possible creating a parody
between physical and digital ownership
that if you bought something and you own
it you can't lose it for reasons that
would not have also affected a physical
purchase now there is even if even if
laws were ever put into place to do that
which currently there are not and so far
as i can tell no one's trying to so this
isn't a problem that anybody in politics
right now appears to even be trying to
fix but even if they did that for a
moment there's still the problem of what
about when the servers get shut down
because like some of these services
allow you to fully download others what
you're buying is access to the thing on
their server what if the company goes
under
what if the server gets shut down
it's still gone
you still lose it
you know if nintendo ever went away went
under bankrupt something was gone
my nintendo systems my nes my super
nintendo my n64 my gamecube the wii that
i barely ever played
they don't suddenly stop working
because the company went under
now we are living in a world with these
digital purchases
and as most of them are still hosted on
servers even though we bought them this
creates a problem not only for consumer
protections and the idea that you own a
thing
but also in addition to that just it
creates a problem for archiving art
like what's going on with infinity train
right now at a certain point when it's
all completely digital
when it's streamed digitally it's made
available digitally the promotion is all
digital
it can effectively be scrubbed from
history
it's like it never existed like on
principle that's kind of messed up
now i did say that right now there's no
legislation that is addressing any of
this that i have been able to find that
is not to say that nobody is trying to
address it there's a woman named amanda
caudell and she attempted to sue amazon
in 2020 she actually attempted to
initiate a class action lawsuit and it
was specifically over this issue
basically she had combed through the
user agreement and she was fully aware
that amazon was capable if it chose for
any reason to claw back and revoke her
access to any movie that she had
purchased through the amazon service and
her argument in court was that the use
of words like buy and purchase play into
an idea of permanent ownership and that
amazon retaining the rights to be able
to revoke that ownership means that they
were misleading their customers
now
this did not actually get to trial it
was dismissed by a judge late last year
the reason being not that there was no
grounding in her
actual claims that that was an issue but
rather it had to do with standing to
bring the lawsuit basically what it what
happened was the judge said
none of your purchases have actually
been revoked
therefore damage has not been done to
you therefore you had no grounds to sue
what amanda caudell was trying to do was
basically trying to force the courts to
make a ruling before it actually started
happening and address the problem
preemptively but courts aren't good for
that courts are meant generally for
remunerations
and or
punishment after something that has
already happened it's not a route that
you can take to try and prevent
something before it happens so the
courts did not actually issue any kind
of relien never saw a jury this idea of
whether or not that is misleading for
some place like amazon to say oh well
you bought that movie digitally when
you didn't
not really not as most of us understand
what a purchase
is
and even if that is false advertising
that's not seeing a courtroom case right
now but i i'm basically on her side in
terms of her claims the fact that amazon
isn't doing that the fact that they have
the ability to
to me that means that it's not a
purchase we don't own it
we rent it
and
it expands out
further we are paying for access to
things but we don't actually own them to
me
to own something
means that i get to retain whatever its
value is
but with digital purchases
especially through streaming services or
you know where it's hosted on a server
somewhere else and you're basically just
buying access to stream it
whatever value it retains
we don't get to have
this was a big part of why video games
have done the big push not only for
digital purchases but for the live
service model of gaming which
thankfully has started to back off a
little bit because they really went in
harder than than was going to work but
that also brings up another thing that
i'll get to in a second but the whole
idea of a live service was we release a
game
and
you know there's the initial you know
people buy the game they buy the game
but you know we're not going to release
another sequel in two years we're going
to continue to serve this it's a live
service it keeps evolving we put out new
content for this thing
then you can buy passes for the new
content you can buy the cosmetics you
can buy this you can buy that
it gives the option for a continual flow
of income as opposed to a single
purchase
and the really the main reason it failed
was that the games sucked
because in theory the promise of a live
service was you initially buy a complete
game that keeps evolving as it goes but
what would usually happen is they
released a bare bones game that was
geared for monetization and not actual
gameplay or fun and then rather than
releasing the promised road map of
content over one two three five ten
years
they were actually spending their entire
time trying to fix the problems and
balance the game in a way that people
would actually want to play the dang
thing in the first place fall behind
never release additional content and
then just shut the whole thing down
after two or three years i.e anthem so
when that happens
whatever money you spend on that game
what is it afterwards
it's nothing the incident incident's not
supported it's nothing but they pushed
it and there are still some live service
games out there and there's certainly
live service elements to a lot of stuff
and a lot of that ties into dlc and
into micro transactions and here's what
i kind of touched on before that i
wanted to come back to
here's what really needs to be
remembered about microtransactions
they used to be a joke
there was a time i'm old enough to
remember a time
when the idea of paying for horse armor
in skyrim
was a joke it was a point of mockery
everybody said this is the stupidest
thing nobody's gonna do it and those
kinds of cosmetic purchases done as
microtransactions are
so beyond standard
nobody questions it anymore
we think oh
they brought out and everyone laughed
so it's not a problem now no
these corporations can and will continue
to hit these things until they are
normalized even if they are points of
nothing but mockery take for instance
what happened
with airlines
and checked bags
there was a time
your first checked bag on a flight
was free
that was the standard
then american airlines decided
we're gonna start charging people for
the first checked bag
and there was some outrage but there was
also a lot of mockery a lot of laughing
a lot of people saying well just go to
another airline then guess what they all
started doing it
they all did it they standardized it and
now
no matter how you fly your first checked
bag is going to cost you money
and if it doesn't that's the exception
it's not the rule anymore
anything that they can standardize
to bring in more money they will
even when it's something as ludicrous
as bmw charging a subscription fee for
heated seats
because let us not forget that that
is now a thing that bmw makers of some
of the most expensive cars in the world
the heated seat feature was a built-in
feature of the car it's the thing the
car can do
you can't access it without paying an 18
a month subscription to heat your own
butt with something that is built into
the thing that you theoretically bought
because they want continuous streams
of income
this is part of why
a lot of these shows that are on
streaming
get limited or even no physical release
because a streaming service is something
that you keep paying for month over
month over month
but if somebody buys stranger things on
blu-ray
netflix only gets money from that
purchase once
but if somebody stays subscribed for
stranger things
waiting for the next season and watching
other stuff in the meantime every month
that's more money
they want the continual feed of money
more than the initial purchase even if
that purchase is higher at least
initially something that i brought up
when i talked about the hbo things
um a lot of editing software i used to
edit
uh with adobe editing software i don't
anymore actually for reasons that aren't
related to this but it allows me to
bring it up anyway and i can slag off
adobe you used to just be able to buy
editing software from adobe and it
wasn't cheap let me be clear the good
stuff like not just the elements but
premiere pro was never cheap to buy
but you used to be able to and now you
can't now it's 200 some odd dollars for
a year's subscription
that you pay monthly for
and so to take someone like me
even if i you know initially had to
shell out 300 to buy
editing software
i now owned it for as long as it works
for me
but
if i'm paying a monthly fee after a year
year and a half
i've now already paid as much as it cost
me previously to just own it forever
and then that keeps going for as long as
i need it and this is my job i need it i
need editing software
this is stuff that is necessary for me
to be able to work
and a lot of these places are moving to
a subscription model
and the thing is
this is not even as new as what i'm
talking about here
these moves from adobe from bmw the
video game stuff this is what
five ten years old
problem's way older than that
because i had the joy of working a
corporate job before i was able to be
able to make this my living support me
on my patreon if you want to be able to
help me continue to make this my living
but
i worked at a job for nine years i
worked in sales
and i remember when they
brought in a new crm that is customer
resource management program and we had
to go through a ton of training on how
to use that and our bosses breathed down
our necks
to use this thing
because
the company was paying
a subscription for it
they wanted to be sure that they weren't
wasting their money
so
at a corporate level this kind of stuff
has actually been going on for a while
and not even just with software john
deere has gotten in trouble for doing
things to attractors so that the actual
farmers who buy these things can't
repair them themselves
monsanto is a company that makes amongst
a ton of other stuff they make seeds and
any farmer who uses seeds that have been
genetically altered by monsanto which is
a lot of them if not most
they can't harvest the seeds from their
own plants and replant them the next
year because the patent on the seeds is
owned by the company
even though you bought the seeds
grew the crops on your land for your
business
you have to buy more from the same
company the next year
you cannot be sustaining yourself
everything is being designed so that we
cannot self-sustain and we have to go
back to these companies
for things that we need not just things
that we want but things that we need
we have to go through them and we have
to keep
paying them
continuously and this is ideal for
corporations because
when you
have to go by the old model which is
make a product
sell a product
and then if you want more money after
that make a new product and then sell
that
you know what's a lot
less expensive to do
make a product and then build a system
so that people pay you continually for
that product and suddenly you aren't
having to do
all the r d all the work to get a new
product out right away before your
income starts to dip
you are on sustained
income
will you still release another product
yeah probably eventually
sometimes uh the money's even better
doing that to bring it back to video
games take destiny destiny was a game
that had a lot of online content and it
was touted that it was going to last for
years gonna be last for 10 years it
didn't cause eventually they decided
actually let's just put out destiny 2.
so maybe you still release a new product
but up until you do you're getting
continual stuff which means you can wait
longer
you can spend less depending on how
you've built the thing to bring it back
again to video games with the live
service model you know what costs a lot
less than building a whole new product
whole new assets whole new um
you know architecture mechanics and
systems and all that
adding more stuff onto something that's
already built
costs less money takes less time
like i said the only reason that the
live service model died as well not
completely died as i said but
failed to latch on the way that it
easily could have is because they were
releasing such
half-baked products if they'd released
good products
that could be the dominant model in
video games right now it's not because
they got greedy and they overstepped it
they released half-baked products and
thought we'd stick around forever for
those you know what we won't but
in theory that is the exact same kind of
model
you have your initial release which they
would still charge people 60 to 70 bucks
for
just like back when you used to be able
to own the thing yourself forever they'd
charge you that and then they would find
ways to nickel and dime you forever
whether it be with season passes whether
it be cosmetic stuff whether it be
gameplay advantages whatever they could
get other money from you and it is
way easier
just to slot in new stuff
a new character a new area into this
existing thing rather than build a whole
thing from scratch why do that that's
more work that costs us more
these places want to make
continuous money
while doing less
that is the point that is why things
that used to be standard
are now
something that we have to pay continuous
continuously for that's why editing
software is rented
that's why bmw is charging for
the ability to turn on your heated seats
that's why again i'm old enough to
remember in games where alternate
costumes and hidden characters and
alternate modes and all the stuff was
just built into the game maybe at most
hidden behind like a cheat code or you
had to progress a certain amount in the
game to get it but it was there you got
it when you bought the thing all that
stuff has been diced up
and now they want to they want you to
pay for it the things that we used to
just get
we don't get any more
they don't want us to own things they
want us to rent
and subscribe
and as i said whatever value is retained
is not ours even if we quote unquote buy
it
because if i had bought when they were
still available the physical copies of
the first two seasons of infinity train
whatever value
probably at least initially diminished
value probably a lot more now because
now you can't get the dang things but
whatever value those dvd copies retained
was mine
i could sell them they became an asset a
minuscule asset they would have been but
they were mine to do with they were mine
to repurpose to cash out on whatever
you can't do that
with the digital purchase and you
definitely can't do that when
what the thing is
is a subscription
or a rental i'm trying very hard not to
simply be recycling things that have
been pointed out by james stephanie
sterling uh if you aren't subscribed to
the gym inquisition you should be
but
they're right especially about the fact
that corporations don't want money they
want all the money
they want every scrap they can possibly
get because when you make a product that
just gets bought there's a limited
amount of money you can make on that
there's only so many people who will
want it
and so even if you market it perfectly
make it available to the right people
easy to get
you're only going to make so much
but if you can make those people
continue to pay you
for access to it
indefinitely
well that is not just more money
that is an unreasonable amount of money
that's an amount of money that's easy to
lose track of that's an amount of money
that becomes a normal part of your life
where every month you just think oh well
this much of my income goes to x thing
when maybe we should be thinking
why am i still paying for this
why don't i own it for how much money i
have sunk into it for how long i've been
paying for this and i'm not saying that
every subscription service is a scam i
do think a lot of things like netflix
like disney plus or what have you like
you get something for what you're paying
for you get access to a lot of stuff
they're putting out a lot of original
stuff so don't mistake me and think that
i'm saying every subscription
service or streaming or whatever is bad
no i think some of them are worth the
money that they charge
but that's the model that these
corporations want to make everything as
much as they possibly can and even
within that model even where i feel like
i'm getting a decent amount of stuff for
my money it's stuff that can be taken
from me
at any moment
that is the world
that these corporations are building
a world where they own everything
and they charge us
monthly for access to all of it
and i kind of wish i had like a lighter
note to end on but i don't
that's where we're headed
that's what they're trying to make
that's what legislators are failing to
do anything about
that's what the courts won't address
that's what's going on
and it's going to continue to be
a bigger and bigger and bigger problem
impacting a higher percentage of things
that is already impacting and it'll
start impacting a wider range of
industries
so yeah i just wanted to use hbo
max as a way to
launch into pointing out just how
screwed up this whole thing is
welcome to capitalism
you'll get your bill at the end of the
month
whatever your thoughts are on any of
this drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it i mentioned my
patreon and yeah yeah i'm sure some
people call me hypocritical well you're
charging a monthly fee for the patreon i
like to think i give people
decent stuff for what i do there's early
access to videos there's the patreon
exclusive discord there's a number of
things check it out why not i can hate
capitalism and still participate i have
to participate
i live in this society
i don't have a choice but to be a
capitalist unless i want to learn how to
forage in the woods
and i don't want to do that
i don't think i'd be good at it i think
i would starve
patreon means i don't starve
begrudge me that
i guess
i gotta find a lighter topic to do
later in the month
ah i'll do my best
we do actually have some fun stuff like
planned for later in this month so
hopefully this will be as heavy as i
need to get
but um
yeah
thank you for sticking this far into it
if you did
what i really want you to remember is
that even as all this nonsense goes on
you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you're the council
i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
time to give my thanks to my highest
supporting patrons that would include
robin moore zubin ludwig to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime
oliver b melinda walters imudelki the
other boy becky sparks fernandi likes
the poodle zach idolin tracy scrabbit
angry casper adam rdl taylor shane ross
shaylee gourley brendan larose and tt
[Music]
if you want your name said while these
guys try and distract me
consider looking at the rewards of my
patreon
[Music]
oh
[Music]